[Music]
coming up on fyi
when was the last time you saw a deaf
actor on tv or in the theater we met
some young actors who want more
opportunities for deaf people the more
deaf people on tv the more awareness we
bring about deaf people
[Music]
and thomas is at goodwood motor circuit
checking out a unique racing competition
do you think you can build an electric
car from scratch and race it well these
guys have
[Music]
this is fyi the week cleaner show where
we bring you all the latest info and you
get to have your say yes and later i'll
be speaking to fy viewers about esports
and whether they think they deserve a
place at the commonwealth games which
are kicking off later this month
and as usual we've been investigating
possible fake news stories do you think
this next story we found is fake news or
fact
[Music]
we found a post being shared online
claiming that dust found on garden
furniture and cars recently was caused
by so-called chemtrails or chemical
trails which are supposedly the trails
in the sky made by airplanes as they fly
the post claims that the dust from these
chemtrails came down in the rain but is
that true or are chemtrails fake news
we'll let you know later in the show
braden did you see that this new 999
british sign language video call service
has just launched so in case of an
emergency deaf people can video call a
british sign language interpreter and
speak to them via bsl instead of texting
that's really good news and hopefully
we'll be seeing more things just like
that because the new british sign
language law has just come into force
which means bsl is now legally
recognised as an official language in
england scotland and wales
it's great news for the deaf community
who have been campaigning for the law
change for years it's hoped that the new
law will mean the language is more
widely used in public services by
hospitals schools and on tv which will
mean more inclusion for the 250 000
people in the uk who use bsl every day
rudy went to meet some young actors from
definitely theater which is the first
ever deaf theatre company in the uk and
they want to see more deaf actors on our
screens and in the theatre
[Music]
this theater group is pretty unique and
its cast members say it shouldn't be
that way
they want their theatre to be inclusive
of everybody both deaf and hearing
audiences so they produce a bilingual
theater which means it's performed in
two languages british sign language and
spoken english
so what does definitely theater mean to
you
definitely theater is special to me
because it helps me build my confidence
it's a really amazing place because we
can build up my skills in creating
pictures with your hands instead of
using words
it includes us deaf people to feel more
involved and
encourage our confidence
[Music]
i like definitely theater because it's
an opportunity to make friends and i
want to become an actor in the future
i'm happy when i'm performing
why do you love bso
signing is so visual
and it shows that you don't have to use
words and you can rely on your hands and
your facial expressions to tell a story
and paint a picture
[Music]
do you think we should all learn british
sign language
yes everyone should learn
deaf people face so many barriers in
communication so it makes so many
breakthroughs
definitely youth theatre was where
actress and strictly come dancing winner
rose ailing alice started out
she was strictly's first ever deaf
contestant and the first ever deaf
character on eastenders she's a real
inspiration to the deaf community i
think it's amazing because she's like my
deaf role model
she shows me that we can do anything
[Music]
i feel really proud of rose
do you think there's enough
representational opportunity for deaf
people in theater or tv
i want to see more deaf people signing
on tv and film and theater because i
think
you know it's not just about the
subtitles
so we need sign language on tv the more
deaf people on tv the more awareness we
bring about deaf people i thought the
rehearsal was so good and it's amazing
to get different people's perspectives
on things and i think a bilingual
theater is a must-see for everyone
you must have seen lorries carrying cars
in their trailers
but have you ever seen them on the back
of a bike this man was spotted in china
transporting a whole car on the back of
his three-wheeler bike pretty impressive
brayden you've heard of formula e right
yeah it's like formula one but with
electric cars exactly so it's been
around for a while now but it's getting
bigger mclaren one of the big racing
teams in formula one has just announced
its involvement in formulary this week
they've unveiled their new electric
racing cars that's pretty cool isn't it
and i reckon thomas has met some of the
formulary races and engineers of the
future he headed to the legendary
racetrack goodwood to see some of the
electric cars that they've built
themselves
[Music]
hey guys loads of teams here today and
it's the first time they'll be racing in
their cars that they built from scratch
it's all part of a competition to
inspire the next generation of engineers
to build electric cars
these guys are team hf24 and they've
come all the way down from derby today
how are you feeling today you must be
excited to race excited a bit nervous as
well i'm definitely excited yeah um
but so far everything's gone quite
smoothly so
i think it'll be all right what do you
have to do in the actual race
it's an endurance race so it doesn't
really matter about being first just as
long as we get to the end
was it challenging to build the car from
scratch yourselves uh yeah it was quite
hard we had to do a lot of wiring
and
we had to do a lot of building stuff and
then taking it apart and then carry on
building it and things like that
and they're off now to the race
well while hf-24 are busy with the race
i caught up with holly a former engineer
who's been helping them along the way
so how did you help these kids out with
building the cars we try and have the
kids building the car as much as
possible because they need to be
confident enough to mechanic it or deal
with any issues that happen we sort of
stood back and the kids did most of the
build themselves
obviously you're not allowed to help if
something goes wrong no they are fully
self-sufficient which is why they need
to be confident enough so we can stand
here and support them but if anything
needs doing with the car they have to do
that on their own
[Music]
okay so the race is over how did you do
there were a lot of like faster cars
than ours but i think we
probably have like the better car
like battery-wise you know i think
because we're sensible with how fast
we're going
what does it mean to you to race here at
goodwood it's a good feeling you feel
proud of yourself being able to do this
and it's really good
well done again guys and i hope you get
a good time in the next qualifying race
and get to the final
nice fun thanks thomas now from formula
e to esports esports is massive and even
has loads of its own worldwide
tournaments yeah the gaming world is
huge did you know you can even do a
degree in esports no i didn't well
that's awesome well for the first time
esports are going to be trialled in the
commonwealth games later this month
there's going to be football car racing
battle games alongside the other usual
sports but do you think it deserves a
place there i headed to west acre middle
school to ask an fy news club what they
think
[Music]
most of us have definitely played a
video game before i'm a bit football
game fan myself but should they be
considered as a sport well i'm here at
west acre middle school to see what your
shout is on this and to see whether
esports should be considered in the
commonwealth games
what do you guys think
i don't think it should because you're
not being physically active when you're
doing esports
i think that it
could be classed as one
people say you don't put enough effort
into training for it but i think they've
put enough effort that they should be
allowed in you have to work your way up
in gaming you can't just turn on a
computer and be
the best player in the world
i don't think it should but it could be
involved in a different one so what
video games do you feel should be
included in the commonwealth games which
games do you think deserve a place there
and do you think violent games should be
included i think that dance should be
included because it's a very active game
and if there are going to be violent
games it should be later on so kids
don't see it while they're watching the
non-scary games i think it should be
only games that like our sports in real
life because it has it in the name
esports i think that if any sports were
going to be added football is a very
like well-known sport around the world
we've come to a i think a good
conclusion there is there anything that
you guys would like to add any like
esports game might encourage the people
actually watching it to try and
do it making people more fit well i
think there were some really good points
there so thank you so much guys
[Music]
remember if you want to have your saren
an issue right here on fyi head to our
webpage at first.news forward slash fyi
you'll get all the info on how to set up
an fy news club at your school
[Music]
so you've probably heard lots in the
news about world leaders meeting at the
g7 summit in germany but have you ever
actually wondered what actually happened
at the g7 summit or what g7 even means
was two
so g7 stands for group of seven
it's the leaders from seven of the most
powerful countries in the world
the uk the united states germany france
canada italy and japan
they all meet and talk about the big
issues facing the planet and this year
russia's war in ukraine dominated the
talks the ukrainian president zelensky
addressed the leaders asking for more
help to end the war and the leaders have
promised more funding and more military
support for ukraine
meanwhile charities are doing all they
can to help the people of ukraine with
the money raised from public donations
the disasters emergency committee has
organised for volunteer cyclists to
deliver food to vulnerable people stuck
in cities where fighting means it's
dangerous for them to leave and
fundraising efforts are carrying on
around the uk as well check these guys
out
in cornwall 300 swimmers attempted to
break the world record for the largest
ever synchronized routine guinness world
records still need to confirm if the
swim few crane routine beat the previous
record of 247 swimmers
fingers crossed
[Music]
now we've got a big congratulations to
say to avi for winning the big bang
competition and being named the uk's
young engineer of the year nice one avi
so we wanted to know more about her
winning invention so she sent us this
video to tell us more
[Music]
i've created a pop-up pavilion that
reacts to the internal co2 levels of the
space inside
throughout the pandemic the need for
space for social distancing and better
air quality became hugely important so i
wanted to explore the concept of a
pop-up pavilion that could provide that
space in healthy indoor air quality
solution
some of the features include a front and
back shutter wall which both open and
close and they're controlled by a
stepper motor there's also a sliding
skylight which opens and closes and
there are warning lights embedded into
the windows of the pavilion to make
users who would be inside it aware
whether they're um
whether the co2 levels are either good
or bad and there's also i'm a fan fitted
on the front and a screen which actually
monitors the
live co2 levels so you're always aware
of that so different functions and
mechanisms surrounding the pavilion will
activate depending on whether the co2
levels or are high or low
i felt really honoured and humbled to
receive the
big bang young engineers of the year
award it was a really great opportunity
for me to speak about my project and to
give me that confidence to go on to
create even more projects and
potentially bigger projects in the
future
engineering is important to me because
it's a way to find solutions to
different problems and it's also a great
way to test your creativity and to
create really awesome and creative
things and what i also enjoy about
engineering is being able to bring the
technology side onto it so being able to
integrate something i've made with code
to make everything move which is what i
find cool and what gives it an extra
touch for me advice i would give to
other inspiring engineers and inventors
is to not be afraid to just give it a go
it doesn't have to be perfect straight
away as long as you have that creativity
and that passion to want to explore it
and just see what you can come up with
and create
well done again abby so did you guess
this week's fake news or fact
[Music]
the post being shared online claiming
that dust found on garden furniture and
cars was caused by so-called chem trails
from aeroplanes is fake news
the dust was actually caused by sand and
dust storms all the way from the sahara
desert in africa
strong winds can carry the dust and sand
as far as the uk and then the particles
in the sky come down in rainfall and
that's when you see the dust covering
cars or garden furniture
yeah the dust particles in the air also
cause these amazing red skies the uk's
national weather service the met office
said it's pretty common in the uk and
happens a few times a year
chemtrails or chemical trails is what's
known as a conspiracy theory where a
small group of people believe airplanes
are leaving behind chemicals rather than
harmless water vapor
the theory has been rejected by experts
and scientists and that's why it's fake
news
remember if you want more help spotting
fake news just head to our webpage first
dot news forward slash fyi we've got
loads of tips and explainers well that's
it from us this week but you can catch
us next week for all the latest info
bye
[Music]